people like to March to their own beat
and it turns out
so do cockatoos palm cockatoos found in
northern Australia and New Guinea are
large birds that are easily recognized
by the rosy cheeks and giant head
feathers but as researchers at
Australian National University found
they have something that other animals
don't rhythm when male cockatoos want to
show off to females they grab a stick or
a seed pod and start whacking a hollow
tree branch this rhythmic tapping is one
of the rare examples of maintaining a
beat found in the animal kingdom animals
as it's whales and other birds produce a
song but these don't have the
well-defined cadence of the palm
cockatoos from apes the use of
rudimentary tools to assist in making
music has only ever been observed in two
species the palm cockatoo and humans not
even chimpanzees humanity's closest
cousin use tools to make music the
analysis of 18 birds and 131 songs
revealed that cockatoos use repeated
elements beat patterns and have rhythms
unique to each individual bird the
cockatoos beat may in the future inform
us as to why cultures developed their
own rhythms and dances and what possibly
came before the first drum was hit
you